♪ I'm cryin' cause I love you. ♪
(upbeat music)
- This card was $35 when I
started buying it a year ago.
That Luka rookie's now $75. I bought,
I was telling everybody on
social media only 30 days ago to
buy them. They were $40.
It is now over $400 TikTok.
Sports cards are coming.
Get educated, get cash.
I know you can see me
talk about sports cards.
My real hot take right
now, it's a flip thing.
Baseball. Soto, Ladd Jr.,
Tatis, Belanger, Mookie Betts.
Baseball that I know a lot
of you aren't in love with is
gonna have a big arbitrage
cause opening day's coming and
people get excited at the new season.
Do your baseball homework.
Thirty, forty hours,
then start buying, then start flipping.
There's three reasons 45 year
olds now have seven year olds
so they're reliving their childhood.
Gambling. $200 for one pack,
but you can pull $150,000 Luka or Zion.
And then finally sports cards
have a lot more volume than
sneakers.
So we have an entire generation
of teenagers who are now in
their twenties that grew up
flipping Yeezys and Jordans,
who now, if they think that
Lamar Jackson's going to
be the guy, they go out and
buy 500, 2,000, 4,000 Lamar rookies.
- Would you rather go graded
cards or would you rather buy
raw and ungraded and try and grade them?
Because I kind of learned
buying raw and ungraded,
you almost need a skill
to almost pregrade them.
- Not a skill. A real, real
skill to pregrade them.
- So there's a real risk/reward thing.
- Or, you buy raw and you sell it raw.
The gentleman a couple of
moments ago bought Lukas for
$15 raw and selling them for $150 raw.
- So just sell them raw? So
don't even try to grade them
if you don't want to put in the time
- Correct
- To like learn and
everything. Okay, got it.
- I would say learn. But
listen, when you don't have
a lot of money and you want to make more
money to both for your
own health of your family,
or because you want to fund
your hobby because you want to
buy some, you know,
Buray PSA 10 rookie cards
cause you decided you
need to build up slowly
and I think raw to raw
is the easiest way to
build up slowly,
- Right.
- This was $80 on eBay two weeks ago.
Now it's $140. That's how I think.
Instead of spending $80 on
a hoodie that makes you feel
fresh, invest in something
and then flip it,
buy the hoodie and pocket for 60 bucks.
Flip life and sports cards are at the top.
If you want to make real money,
this is no joke. Go to eBay
and buy Giannis rookie cards.
#290, 2013 Penini Prizm,
PSA 10 graded.
They're 300 bucks, $250
to 300 bucks right now.
God forbid they win the
finals this year and stun
the Warriors. It'll be
$600, but even if not,
unless he has a catastrophic injuries,
this is the best player
in the NBA in four years.
And this is an $800 card at four years.
So think about it. You put in 300, 800.
That's good. Cause you
can flip it right away.
If you got a little money, $3,000, $8,000.
- Several months later.
- Yeah. Listen.
We (beep) up.
- Thing called pack breaking.
Basically people buy slots in
boxes of cards where you get
the third pack that he opens
live on Facebook or whatever
live platform. You know, you
can call it a form of gambling,
a form of contests. But
like literally for example,
there's a famous one 86-87 full
year with the Jordan rookie.
- Yeah.
- People pay $2,000 a pack and then if
you get a Jordan or in his world, like..
- Wait, how brilliant, brilliant.
- It's super brilliant.
It's also super entertaining to watch.
I watch pack breaks that I'm
not even in just waiting for
the big card to come out of the pack.
Sport's cards different.
It's not about the million
dollars that I'll make in
flipping cards in the next
three years and I will.
It's about the tens of
thousands of kids that
I'm going to impact.
I'm excited about pushing
people and teaching them how to
make money instead of raising
money and raising money has
become the sport of
entrepreneurship in this era.
Not making it.
And it's something that I'm
trying to bring conversation to.
- There you go.
- Let's (beep) go!
- Guess. Guess the price of the card.
So here's a Serena Williams.
- 8 bucks.
- $8.13. Wow. Okay.
- Let's (beep) go!
- Cristiano Ronaldo
- 27
- 11
Michael Jordan. Bulls. Right here.
- 60 bucks.
- 25. Sam Darnold 2008
- 14 bucks.
- Exactly. 14 bucks. There you go.
- Let's (beep) go!
Are these your cards?
- I bought these for this.
That's (beep) amazing.
- On the money. That's great.
- I love it.
My first baseball card show,
I wanted to pay $20 for the table,
the whole way to the Phillipsburg
Mall, me and my partners
at the time were going to pay $20.
We get there some monster
guy that looks like King Kong
Bundy comes out and he goes, "What?"
And we're like, we want a table.
You got any? And he's like,
yeah, we got one more.
How much?
He goes $120. I go, we'll take it.
Bring the money tomorrow
and then we just like
start walking out of the mall
and my friends are in a coma.
You know, like $120 is like a
billion. And I'm like, cool.
And they start getting
nervous and like, you know,
like what am I going to
do? And like, I've got it.
But like that seems like a whole lot.
And my dad who I've never talked
to back then to his credit,
he says, it's going to
be worth the experience.
And honestly, maybe from that day on,
that has been a credo of
mine. Everything I do,
the second I decided to
do it, I had already won.
And whether it worked or not,
the learnings were
going to be the KPI ROI.
I've been investing in
sports cards for 18 months.
Last April and May and June,
I bought 15 LeBron rookies and
now they grade them. 50
perfect 10's at $1,050 a piece.
Now they're selling for $4,000 a piece.
- Wow.
- Sports cars are exploding Jim.
I need everybody who's listening
right now to really go to
stock X and eBay and see what's going on.
- Gary, if I'm a kid at home
trying to flip cards right now,
what do I do?
- You gotta lean into self-awareness like,
do you know Pokemon? Do
you know like basketball?
Do you know? But if you
know a sport by the legends,
LeBron, Kobe, Shaq. They
always will work out or
buy the kid that you believe in.
That's gambling but that gets crazy.
- Does that translate to
something like Pokemon?
Like something fictional.
- Because you're in, it's
so nerdy that, you know,
like a character is actually
slightly underrated and all the
homies talk about it and it can pop.
It's why bought a bunch of
Black Panther comics back in the day.
I nailed that one. If
you really know Pokemon,
go spend five hours in a Pokemon
(beep) forum or on Pokemon
Twitter and just figure
out like who this character
gets talked a lot about
but then go to Ebay.
This is 10 hours of work. It's strategy.
TikTok entrepreneurs, sports cards,
their back. Flip life. Do
you want to make money?
Buy cards for less than you sell them?
Dude, I'm telling you right
now, I'm not (beep) around.
If this conversation was
happening in October. I'd be like,
please buy two Giannis
rookies. They're 170 bucks.
They're going to go up.
They're (beep) 450 now.
The real thing to do is buy
these basketball cards that are
about to come out and try to pull.
It's gambling.
You pull a (beep) $5,000 Zion rookie card.
I think it's like one of the
scariest guaranteed 50 to a
100 percent up ticket value in 24 months,
completely liquid things I've
seen in a very long time.
TikTok, listen to me.
I want you to make your
moneys on sports cards
so what you're watching here
right now is me talking to my
admin, Lou, who's in
sports cards roll with me,
and what I'm doing here is I'm
telling him to look into the
population numbers. How much supply?
How many of these rookie cards are made
and you can see he's replying
to me with the volume and
Akuna and Pete Alonzo
are super hot right now.
So you see the bigger numbers,
and I was thinking about
Belanger and Pettis
and so I'm really thinking
about it at that point.
Now you can see,
I want Belanger because
I really want to start,
and this is me buying it at 120 bucks.
And so what's crazy about that
is I paid 120 bucks just a
couple of weeks ago.
It's now it's like 230.
We'll put it up here. A $230-$300 card.
From those early packs to, you know,
getting into the baseball
card collecting club in
sixth grade and really learning the game
to doing card shows in eighth grade.
I really, I learned so much,
so much of what I do today at
Vaynermedia or how we built
Empathy Wines or how we navigated
Rezi or how I invested or
how I see things. You know,
why was I right about Facebook
and Twitter and social media
or email.
It really started from that
first buyer card for $3 because
you think Eric Davis is a good
baseball player and you think
the Reds are good that
year and then they go to
the World Series and that
card is $6 and you sell it.
Now, you're like, wow,
I have three more dollars
than I started with.
What I know is happening
and I think a lot of
people are not realizing it's happening
to them is they're learning
so much more than they realize
about humans, about consumer
demands, about markets,
about supply and demand around
marketing and merchandising,
something you own.
Around hard work.
You know, there's a lot of
learnings going on and to me,
that's why I'm so excited
about the garage sale or the
sports card stuff that it's
teaching underlining principles
that I think are scalable in the future.
Hey, everybody on YouTube,
first of all, thank you so much.
So humbled for your time. If
you got some value out of that,
there's plenty more where that came from.
Feel free to check it out.